[Music]
here in Italy when Co hit it was a huge
traumatic event Italy went under the
first national lockdown of any democracy
since World War II that meant that first
schools closed and then shops closed and
then finally uh all non-essential
industry um that meant you know plants
that were making Automobiles and pipes
um these are all industries that consume
a lot of electricity and when that
demand went down for electricity that
transformed the
market Energy prices
tanked but Power traders in Italy were
able to rake in huge
sums and grid operators passed the bill
on to Italian businesses and the
public this is a story about power
profit and the pandemic
there's a maneuver in the market that
some researchers have called gaming and
it's a kind of a simple thing if you
don't want to sell the good that you
have at a low price um you keep it off
the market and wait until someone really
needs it when that happens you can
charge a much higher price in the power
Market in those first days of Co in
particular uh we found that there a
single power plant could make millions
of Euros every day keeping their power
off the market and then selling it
sometimes 5 10 some cases 40 times the
regular
[Music]
price Corona
virus
doing this investigation meant talking
to as many people as we could within
this sort of obscure corner of of the
markets um which is power trading
day-to-day in Italy this is not like the
stock markets the bond markets where
there's huge transparency through
talking to these people and crunching
the data something sort of came to life
there was an EB and flow there was a
pattern to the way this trading happened
on slow days where there wasn't a lot of
demand and the prices were low all of a
sudden some of this trading was shifting
to the secondary Market the dispatch
Market which could pay a lot more
money Ator bompard is a professor of
Power Systems at the poly Technic
University of Torin
basically if you are a market player you
can decide if you want to to offer your
capacity in the energy Market or in
theary service market and this perfectly
let's say legal you are a market player
you have you have to exploit the market
rules to maximize your payoff your
profit and sometimes what happened is
that uh you can
avoid to offer Your Capacity because you
know that thanks to the physical
property the physical constraints and
operational constraints of the network
your unit is Surly needed in a given
hour of the day to remove congestion or
to be able to control the voltage
profile this isn't a new practice for
years during slow days Italian power
companies found a way to bring in much
more money than the regular electricity
Market was
offering Italy is sh like a boot and at
the top you have Turan Milan Venice and
it's just a big group of wires where you
can kind of Supply everywhere but you go
down that boot and you have a mountain
range and it's the coast and down that
Coast you have Rome and Naples and you
get to the bottom the heel of the boot
you have brindes and then you have the
islands like Sicily and Sardinia and
they aren't really completely connected
to the National Grid and that's where
some of these producers were able to
pump up their price on the secondary
Market because they weren't selling on
the regular market and they made a lot
of money in some cases uh they got
caught in the Naples area there were
three plants that were pivotal to
maintaining the voltage on the grid and
in
2010 uh there was an anonymous tip and
somebody said to the antitrust
authorities you have a cartel and the
antitrust authorities and the Italian
Regulators looked into it every Sunday
there would be plant one then the next
Sunday plant two and then plant three
and then they would take a turn and go
through the same cycle over and over
again and the investigation found that
there had been some communication among
these plants um and they were fined the
fines totaled about €300,000 one of the
trading heads of one of the plants told
us
peanuts Italians generally have no idea
that this was happening your electric
bill comes in and not only is it very
complicated with mowatt hour megawatt
hours with the amount of your
consumption whether your meter was red
or not there's a line on there with
these extra costs these come from
Trading strategies these are the costs
of maintaining the grid of making sure
there are no blackouts um and during
coid when those costs went up but the
expense for the power itself went down
you just ended up with a bill that was
about the same as it was before um and
as somebody said you know an extra
billion of costs wasn't going to be
noticed by anybody once you divide it up
among households and
[Music]
businesses see it's
legal
[Music]